esta aldea está aproximadamente a 100
kilómetros de kiev las tropas rusas
pueden haberse ido pero un nuevo peligro
se ha instalado en esta parte del país
en el norte y el este de la capital
ucraniana
dando bola señor podría venir a mi casa
hay un agujero en la pared y puede que
haya una bomba dentro
de este equipo de expertos en limpieza
de minas no puede atenderle ahora están
siendo llamados constantemente
misiles minas hay al menos 10.000
explosivos solo en estas dos aldeas
les han llamado desde un campo de trigo
donde un avión de combate ucraniano fue
derribado hace aproximadamente un mes
algunos de sus cohetes no explotaron y
tienen que ser destruidos
el equipo coloca un pequeño cohete cerca
de un misil sin detonar e instala el
aparato que les permite encender la
mecha a distancia
vamos para allá
[Música]
hay miles de estos repartidos para acá
espere ya llegó
las tropas rusas también han atrapado
algunas de estas zonas que ocuparon
nuestro territorio y provocó que
encontramos un explosivo en este jardín
detrás de mí
estaba escondido en una batería vamos
con mi vida
powerball
el equipo de expertos rápidamente
desactiva el dispositivo pero la
propietaria todavía está aterrada
y estoy muy asustada por dejar mi casa
justo por eso tengo las ventanas
cerradas estoy asustada todo el tiempo
las autoridades ucranianas creen que hay
300.000 km cuadrados de área que tienen
que ser inspeccionadas un área del
tamaño de polonia